[Musique]
lettre à la république à tous et
racistes à la tolérance hypocrite qui
ont bâti leur nation sur le sens tueur
d'afrique
con comme ça ce passé colonial c'est le
font les fous qui avait choisi de lier
votre histoire
tab est ici plus longtemps si j'ai toute
ma vie j'ai mon petit frère
j'ai ma mère est
puis le contraire
la vie c'est une question de choix c'est
tout sauf que toi ton choix il a tué
papa c'est mon chien d'adieu parma
aujourd'hui pour moi la paix et semant
l'effroi chez moi dit je n'ai rien à
voir avec toi
car ceux ci ne pas se manquer de parler
tu nous as il va chercher jette pas un
troquet lula qui suit le même schéma
je vais maintenant vous révéler le sujet
de votre débat l'état est il seul
responsable de la situation actuelle des
banlieues en fait vous avez la parole
la banlieue je la connais lorsque 2
balls a replongé dans le trafic de
d'entente entre dans une pierre pour des
raisons strictement pécuniaires et que
cette guerre un bon tiers à mort de l'un
d'entre eux est ce l'état qui fournit
larmes à la sacem
lui ordonnent ou presque on voit malgré
lui sur la détente
j'emmerde votre jules j'emmerde votre
hypocrisie de
top je t'aime aussi gérer des très
courageuse
alors qu'est ce qui t'es arrivé jeune
fille on va à minneapolis
c'est un accident suis tombé
tu cèdes oktar c'est le cas pour nous
tous n'est ce pas pop et j'ai failli te
rattraper j'aimerais faire un scanner
pour être sûr qu'il n'y a pas de lésion
interne va s'occuper tout je vais
attendre juste ici que tu remontes
ça fait des heures j'attends vous savez
si ça va être encore long quel est son
nom perry monroe et je ne vois aucune
perry manon ya eu qu'un seul scanner ce
matin à 9 heures se veut dire quoi
elles sont pas ici c'est la liste de
tous les patients de la journée je n'ai
pas trouvé un seul monroe je veux juste
voir ma femme et ma fille vous avez des
images de l'intérieur des urgences il
n'y a pas de caméras dans les salles de
traitement elles sont sous la caméra on
peut pas les voir sur six césars il n'ya
pas un mais yang
vous avez examiner ma fille et vous
savez soigner son bar le seul élément
que j'ai c'est votre parole qu'elle
était bien ici vous croyez que je les
ardentes et ou gazeux pourquoi j'aurais
bruit les chapes de ma vie est belle
je sais jusqu'à un truc qui tient bat
mois
je vous ai montré les photos ça peut
être n'importe qui
on est aussi inquiet pour elle que
voulait pourriez l'hôpital personne ne
sera blessé
keita tard et ça se voit
mais c'est tout
ce que vous avez fait de ma famille
qu'est ce que vous avez pen mané
[Musique]
lorsque sur revenu à la maison il ya
longtemps jeté un homme perdu déjà
rencontré comme horaire
j'avais une famille je le serais même
pas
je dois aller jusqu'au mexique j'ai
retrouvé mon père on se moque du bien
que nunca ses reportages comme de patrie
c'est louis qui se comporte comme ton
père il est allé au mexique et elle est
parvenue
qui sont ils
et frère ma petit nice
je dois à ramener à la maison
tu as détesté
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout ce qui lui reste c'est moi je veux
ma vengeance
je veux qu'il le sache la mort
est en chemin
à crystal bien vivant
[Musique]
me détacher le quart
c'est la mort que le trouveront
je vais te mettre en pièces
[Musique]
vous avez commencé je vais finir
je vais te faire très mal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à gauche combien de fois je dois te le
répéter tu lèves et moi mesdames
j'ai apporté mes visites pour aider à
mettre en place cette fête de l'eau ce
soir ça va être vraiment épique
ou et l'alcool
la meilleure fête de l'année je vais
pouvoir tout va les faire couper
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est que ça j'y vais
c'est une très mauvaise idée
pourquoi tu veux y aller mais qd a déjà
regardé l'histoire de cette maison
des gens ont été tués ici beaucoup par
dow cfd mois
mais la famille qui vivait ici punaise
on doit y aller ouvrir la porte
[Musique]
5 4 3 2
à
à 20h50
à 10 en 2010
[Musique]
tout pas la lumière à cape town tu
savais que ta maman allait pâtir en jour
c'est très très peur peur
[Musique]
moi je gardais saborit
add your est tout à leur honneur par mac
os 15
[Musique]
tu es là
ça va pas non tu m'as fait peur par
sinon ce fonds
je profite pas
cette maman
ces deux mâchoires du bar
[Musique]
avant tout le monde
il était aisé
vous êtes étudiant tous les journalistes
je fais de la photo moi je j'ai 25 ans
25 ans t'as pas peur non
c'est la presse et la presse
la centrafrique retient son souffle
presque personne qu'il y à trois jours
et c'est les cas sont passés porte à
porte qui les ont tué mon voisin ils
sont entrés chez moi tu rencontres pas
les deux un côté d'objectifs la prison
de l'autre copat mettre à leur place est
impossible jeu je sais pas si cela vous
n'êtes pas chez vous vous étiez vous
c'est moi tu dois marquer les autres tu
deviens tu prends etupes a commis une
grande photographe du fait de protéger
humain c'était une fois ci je cherchais
un ami qui s'appelle syrie partie au
fond de moi non non je voulais pas vous
dire quel requin
le visiteur à oignies dj am a man
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]